I'm dr. Aaron - and this is dr. Rob
Williams and Sammy Williams and we are
from oceans initiative with this
coronavirus we've decided well I guess
we can't do fieldwork and so we can't go
out on the boat we can't study killer
whales or dolphins or sharks or salmon
we decided to bring a virtual marine
biology field camp to our house and we
thought kids might want to follow along
and that way we're home but we're not
alone one of our projects that we
typically use this time of year is the
track Civic white-sided dolphins
[Music]
and one of the way that we study
white-sided dolphins is to take
photographs of their dorsal fin the
markings are unique to many dolphins in
here we've named one Kelly Kelly the
dolphin she's a couple of Nick's that no
one else has next time when we go out in
the field we'll be able to pick her out
of the dolphin crowd helps us find out
if their population is healthy and going
up or down and if we need to do
something help them we created this
little activity for you to try at home
to see if you can match Kelly the
dolphin I hope that you enjoy the
activity and that you can follow along
with our virtual marine biology camp
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going